jalani to continue to telling us about
sketching high dimensional data all
right so today i'll talk more about
more examples of linear sketching
and also uh dimensionality reduction
so you know johnson lindenstrasse for
example
so you know one of the early papers um
from the mid-90s in in the area of
sketching and streaming was this
paper by alone mantis and sagitty
and it was lp norm estimation
um of a vector
x being updated in a turn style stream
so just remember that means if i say
update
i delta that means that x i gets
incremented by delta or delta could be
positive or negative
and you know one of their results was
this ams sketch
which said that um we can estimate
the l2 norm up to 1 plus epsilon
with with probability at least one minus
delta
using of one or epsilon squared log one
over delta
words of memory
okay and you know how does that
let's uh let's see how to do that
so it's a linear sketch um
and their intersections as follows they
said pi
is this matrix where each entry
is plus minus one over root m
and you have m rows here and columns
and what you're going to do is you're
going to maintain
y which is pi x in memory
and then you're going to estimate
x squared by y squared
okay and i'm not going to do i'm not
going to go through the
you know all the calculations i'll just
show you basically what goes into it
it's
nothing too complicated just first of
all you show that
the expectation of y squared is in fact
correct you can just write that down and
verify
as long as
the plus minus one are two y's
independent remember we talked about
ky's independent hash functions before
okay
and also the variance
of y squared
is o of one over
m times the l two norm x to the fourth
and this is as long as the plus minus
ones
are four wise independent
okay
and i don't want to spend time i mean
there's a lot of stuff i want to tell
you today i want to spend time on
uninteresting calculations but you know
why does this come up
well you know what is the variance of of
this random variable is just depends on
you know the second moment
so what is what is y l2 norm squared
this is of course the sum of y i squared
which is the sum
let me call actually sum over r of y r
squared
and this is um 1 over
m times the sum r goes from 1 to m
times the sum i goes from 1 to n of i'll
say
sigma r i y uh
or sorry x i
right this is the l2 norm squared so
when i look at the second moment of this
random variable
that means i'm raising it to the fourth
power
to the fourth then all of this gets
squared
right so here i'm going to start getting
terms that look like
you know sigma
sigma r1
uh i1 sigma r1
i2 sigma r2
i3 sigma r2 i4
right assuming it's some double sum
1 over m squared some stuff like this
and then when i when i look at the
expectation of the second moment
you know i'm basically gonna have to
deal with expectations of terms that
look like this
and the point is there are only ever
four signs at a time that are involved
so as long as these signs are four-wise
independent
it determines the second moment right so
i don't need full randomness in my in my
matrix
okay but you know that's where that's
where
the bounded independence suffices
okay so
once you have this you plot you just do
chebyshev's inequality
and then you can get um success
probability you know 99
so all this stuff together implies
with you know m being one over epsilon
squared
you get let's say ninety percent
success probability
so if you want success probability of
one minus delta you repeat this
structure
log one over delta times or o of log one
or delta times and you take the median
results out of all of them
right so it's going to be the median of
many such estimators
and that gives you the space found that
i showed you okay
one optimization time wise
so let's say a faster algorithm using
the same space
is is basically the count sketch
by chary car whoops charity car
chen and ferris colton
and o2 and then you know for
specifically for using it for l2
estimation
you can look at thor bin zhang you know
four
so let's think about you know what is it
what are you actually doing
um in the stream like what is your ally
what are your streaming algorithm
actually doing
to update itself every time you see an
update so
you're maintaining you're supposed to be
keeping track of this vector x
subject to updates that look like you
know x i gets to be
x i plus delta this is update i delta
well this is the same thing this is the
same thing as
x gets x plus delta times the i standard
basis vector
so we're maintaining
pi x right so that means that pi x
gets to be pi x plus
delta times the ith column of pi
so pi is this
pi is this you know short wide matrix
and every time there's an update you're
taking some column of pi
scaling it and then you know adding to
the sketch
now in our previous you know the ams
sketch that i just showed you on the
last whiteboard
pi was a dense random matrix right every
entry was plus minus 1
over root m um
it would be nice if pi were a sparse
random matrix right
because let's say pi only has one
non-zero entry for example
then it's very fast to add any column
represented every column of pie only has
one non-zero entry that is very fast
to update our sketch we either we add
the ice column of pi that that only has
one non-zero it only takes us constant
time to do that
right and in fact you can do that so the
count sketch looks like this matrix
and we're going to see this matrix more
today as well as tomorrow
each column
you pick one uniformly random location
you make it b plus minus one and the
rest of the column is all zeros
so you can imagine you have two hash
functions hash function one
uh maps for each column it tells you
where the non-zero entry is
and then you have another hash column
and another hash function which for each
column it tells you
is the random sign there going to be a
plus one or a minus one
okay so these two hash functions
determine the matrix
okay um
and again a claim that i'm not going to
do for you so the claim
is that if y
equals pi x for pi
equals the count sketch
then i still have the same thing the
expectation of y l two norm squared is
x l two norm squared and the variance
of this of this random variable um
is equal to o of one over m times
l two l to the fourth
okay and again you only need
you know four four wise independence to
make things work
so this is basically the same
performance as the ams sketch in terms
of memory
but you're getting run time or update
time which is only constant
instead of whatever epsilon squared now
again if you want to amplify the success
probability
to 1 minus delta you'll repeat this log
when a result of times
so now your update time will be log 1
over delta
but it'll only be log 1 over delta as
opposed to log 1 over delta times
epsilon squared
one over some squared of the ams sketch
so this is strictly faster
okay um
now after this
so this is strictly for this for the l2
norm specifically what about other
norms what about other lp norms so for
zero less than p less than or equal to
two let's say less than two
if p is less than one it's not a norm
but it's still a defined function of x
uh index
showed that this similar
space bound is possible
here and you know what was the idea
there
so definition
a distribution
d over r is
p stable
if for all
uh vectors x and rn
if say z1 up to zn our
iid from this distribution that if you
look at the random variable the sum
of z i x i
this should be distributed like
basically another variable variable
distributed according to z
scaled by the lp norm of x
where z is also distributed according to
b
okay
can you all hear me well by the way yeah
okay
um now examples
if p equals two then this is for example
the gaussian distribution
right if you add independent gaussians
you get a gaussian and the variance is
just add
right the l2 norm would be like the
standard deviation
of the of the resulting sum
and you know there is something right
called the central limit theorem which
says if you add lots of copies
you know independent copies of i from
some distribution
you should get something that eventually
becomes a gaussian
uh so like why would you ever have a
scale factor that's not the l2 norm
and the answer is that you know the
central limit theorem requires bounded
variance right
so if you were to have a p stable
distribution for p not equal to two
then it would have to be that that um
this distribution d
has unbounded variance otherwise you
would be violating the central limit
theorem
and in fact the theorem is that
these distributions do exist
if and only if uh basically
p is in the interval from zero to two
if p is bigger than two they don't exist
um
okay
so good now what is index algorithm
i'm sorry okay this seems to
let's go here okay um so what is index
algorithm his matrix pi
looks like as follows
each one of these entries is distributed
according to
uh i'll call it zr let's let's actually
call it
zri is distributed according to this
distribution d
the for the p for p okay so the the p
stable some p stable distribution
and again he has m rows where it's going
to turn out that m is going to be
two chosen to be something that's
roughly one or epsilon squared times
some constant
okay now how do you you know
what is this estimator so you store
y which is pi x and you estimate
the alpena of x by um
by the lp by the median entry
of y
divided by the median
of the absolute value of dp what do i
mean by that so
if you plot dp dp looks like it's as
follows
and it's some distribution and then look
at look at a random variable
which is distributed in the following
way you sample from dp and you take its
absolute value
okay so then now you get some
distribution
that you know looks something like this
and i want to know
what is the median of this distribution
meaning what's the value
some value such that if you look
to the right and to the left of the
value basis of that value the amount of
probability mass here is exactly a half
so this this is what i'm saying i'm
calling the median of the absolute value
distribution
okay i mean you can always scale let's
scale the distribution so that this
thing is
is one
okay so we can
we can we can uh ignore that from now on
okay so why is this so that's it that's
the algorithm
um of course there's an issue here in
that you know these are real
real valued random variables i have
finite precision on my computer
ultimately
ultimately i'd like to say that i use
you know bounded memory and bits
that can be handled just by rounding
just you know round whenever you sample
around these numbers to finite precision
you can do that calculation and it's all
fine
there's also the issue that um you know
these are as i said it all all the
entries in this matrix are
iid so this is a very big random matrix
um and you know it's expensive to store
a big random matrix memory wise
with the ams sketch that wasn't an issue
because the entries are only four wise
independent
so i could generate the whole matrix
using only a log n bit seed
but here if i require independent
entries to get the p stability property
then it's not clear
um it's not clear then how to generate
this with low memory right but we'll get
to that
so how do you analyze this so
the way he analyzes this is as follows
now what do we know we know that
the expectation okay so first of all
um
[Music]
for all r we know that um kind of y
r is distributed like
basically dp
times the lp number of x so let me just
bring this
divide by the l p number over here and
get rid of that
so we know that each entry of y as if
you scale down by the lp number of x is
a p stable random variable
which implies that
the expectation of
remember now what i say the median of
the absolute value of the distribution
is
is one i scaled it that way in other
words the amount of probability mass in
the distribution between minus one and
one
uh is a half
does this make sense so i'm saying
look at the indicator function of an
interval the interval from minus one to
one
okay what's the expectation of the
indicator function
of the interval it's the probability
that the random variable lands in that
interval okay so the probability that it
lands in that the problem that y r
lands in that interval is exactly a half
because i scaled this
stable distribution so that exactly half
the mass lies between minus one and one
okay so and the distribution you know
i'm not going to justify this here but
believe me it's true the distribution
does you know have some kind of
bell shape like this okay
so um if you look at the expectation
of
actually let me do the following
if you look at
the expectation of
the sum r goes from one to m
let me put a one over m here as well
of the indicator function of minus 1
minus epsilon 1 plus epsilon
evaluated at y r
okay so what is this what does this
thing mean
this means what what fraction
of the entries of y do i expect so we
what do we know we know that
the amount of mass between minus one and
one the amount of mass
here is a half right
now if i tell you that this is what the
distribution looks like
if i go out if i now go out here
to minus one minus epsilon and one plus
epsilon
right
if i go out there there's some
additional mass now that i've gained
right
so first of all by linearity of
expectation
this is the same thing as you know
basically pushing the expectation inside
to each one of these indicators
right so we we know what that is so what
is what is
let me ask you what is the expectation
of the indicator of minus 1 minus
epsilon 1 plus epsilon evaluated at y r
right so this thing is just
basically uh 1 over m times the sum r
goes from 1 to m of this
what is this
i don't know this is a question for you
to make sure we're all on the same page
here
or kind of roughly what is it
oh i guess people in the webinar can't
talk can they okay i forgot that this is
uh
okay well chat it someone sent it in the
chat
i know it takes time to type things
but okay so
i guess when people can't talk when they
have to chat it's not as
efficient so so the point is look like
if the distribution really looks like
this
then you know previously the amount of
mass in that black area was a half
i widened it a little bit by epsilon on
each side i gain you know some theta
epsilon
so the point is that this thing is going
to be a half
plus some theta of epsilon okay and
similarly
if i look at the expectation of one over
m
sum are goes from one to m of the
indicator
of minus one plus epsilon one minus
epsilon evaluated at y r
this thing is a half minus theta epsilon
right that's basically if i
if i went if i went in a little bit
right so what is this saying
this is saying that an expectation at
least you know
more than half the entries more than
half the entries are
are under some threshold
and less than half the entries are
smaller than some threshold right what
am i happy
i'm happy basically i'm happy if the
median
if the median actually an absolute value
is somewhere in this like teal region
right in between uh
minus or actually the teal region is all
of this
right if the median if the median is
somewhere in there then i'm happy
okay now if i know that
this is proof by picture if i know that
less than half let's just focus on the
kind of the positive numbers right now
okay let's look at the absolute value if
i know that
less than half are in this red region
or in this region if i know that less
than half are here
and that more than half are here
it means that the median has to be
somewhere in here
right so i'm happy when this happens
i'm happy when you know if this if this
happens not only an expectation but
actually happens that a half plus theta
fraction are in that interval i'm happy
and if this also happens that a half
minus
theta epsilon fraction are in that
interval i'm also happy
so i'm happy when both of these two
events happen you know remove the
expectations
if it's actually true that one over m
times the sum of these indicators is
half plus theta epsilon and one over m
times some of these indicators is half
minus theta epsilon
from these two different intervals i'm
happy now
now i want to say that not only does it
have an expectation but it happens with
decent probability
and for that i can get that from a
turn-off bound a natural note chubby
shoves inequality
right because i know that
the variance of
one over m times the sum of whatever y
r if these are independent random
variables
if the rows are independent then this is
um 1 over m squared
times the sum r goes from 1 to m
of the variance of this indicator
now what is the variance of that
indicator i have no idea but
what i do know is that it's at most one
because
the indicator itself is always between
zero and one
and that's enough so this is at most one
over m squared
or one over m sorry because they're m
they're m things that i'm summing
one over m squared times m which is one
over m
so i know the variance is bounded by one
over m so if i pick m to be big enough
if i pick
m to be some big constant times one over
epsilon squared
chubby chef tells me that with 90
probability i will get this
and also with 90 probability i'll get
this as well
so my union bound with 80 probability
i'll have both the events that i want
and the median will in fact be in the
range that i want it to be in to
guarantee a one plus up slot
approximation
okay so that's it okay it's basically
just
follows again by that by a second moment
calculation
and applying chebyshev's inequality okay
now if you inspect the proof where did
we use independence
okay we used it in two places i used
independence
right here to say that
the variance of the sum is the sum of
the variances
and i also used independence you know
in these two places you know right here
and also right here why
because i said you know i wanted to
calculate
the expectation of the indicator
function of an interval of this random
variable y r
right what is y r i said y r is a p
stable random variable
and i know what a p stable random i know
what the p stable distribution looks
like so i know how much mass is in some
interval
how do i know that y r is a p stable
random variable
because it's the sum of independent p
stable random variables so i'm using
independence there
okay so that's the second place i'm
using independence it's it's to
guarantee that
y r is p stable so that i can understand
how much mass is in certain intervals
how much probability masses in certain
intervals
okay so the first one is easy to fix
so i want to say that this variance of
the sum
is equal to the sum of the variances
but as long as the random variables are
at least two eyes independent
that's true you don't need full
independence for this to be true you
just need pairwise independence
so i can just make sure that the rows of
the matrix are pairwise independent
i don't need full independence across
the entire matrix
now what about the entries within a row
now there i don't need to actually have
that you know it's not it's not crude
it's not crucial for me that
y r is p stable i just want the
distribution of y r to be approximately
p stable
okay what what does approximately p
stable mean in this case it means that
the kind of the komogorov distance
between this distribution
and an actual p stable distribution is
at most epsilon
and you know if you don't homogeneous
just means look at the l
infinity distance of the cdfs i want it
to be the case that
for any interval the amount of
probability mass in that interval
compared with an actual p stable random
variable
are close to each other within an
additive epsilon
okay and it turns out that so i want to
say that you know
um if you look you know for all let's
say for all
q if i look at the probability
that an actual p stable distribution is
at most q
versus the probability that you know my
sum
the sum of um let's say y
y i x i
is at most q where this thing has
p norm 1 and these things are only say
k y's independent
i want that this thing to be at most you
know epsilon let's say
right if that's true then i'm still
happy because i still can do the proof
that i just showed you
and in fact this is true for k
being o of one over epsilon to the p and
this was shown by
daniel kane myself and woodruff
in 2010
okay so i mean that's that's one way to
de-randomize it
optimally um in his original paper indic
had a different way to de-randomize it
the randomizing it using a
nissan pseudorandom generator which gave
a good bound but
um you did lose a little bit by doing
that
okay so
that's good so any any other any
questions before i move on
okay let's continue
so what about other norms
for example lp for p bigger than two
okay and the theorem there
and this is due to bar yosef
jram kumar
and shiva kumar in o2
is that for p greater than two
you know some constant approximation
of lp in a stream
requires um
omega n to the one minus two over p bits
of memory
right so you know if p is less than two
then
this this doesn't really say anything
but once p is bigger than two
um this is a polynomial this is a
polynomial lower bound
right so if p is if p is three
approximating the l three norm requires
n to the one cubed
n to the one third so and yeah went into
the one third bits of memory
so there is no logarithmic space
algorithm there is no polylog space
algorithm
okay and this is actually tight
absolutely you know log factors and
there's been work on reducing the log
factors but
um you know for example in dick and
woodruff
i don't believe it's five maybe so six
said that um
well sorry they said that
up to log factors um n to the 1 minus 2
over p
is possible there is an algorithm
there's a streaming album that actually
achieves that
and i'm not going to show you i'm not
going to show you the proofs of
either of these however i will show you
kind of
why why the bound is n to the 1 minus 2
over p
and where are not the full y but part of
the y
okay so the lower bound
is via communication complexity
and it's a reduction
from multi-party sentence jointness
okay so so what's going on there
so the setup
is you have a bunch of players so you
have player one player two
up to player t
each one has a subset of one to n so
this person has s1 which is a subset of
one to n
this person has s2 which is a subset of
one to n and this person has sn or
st receptive one day
so they're promised
that either
for all i not equal to j s i
intersect sj is empty there are no
pairwise intersections
or
basically um
they do intersect so
and i think it's even stronger than that
you're even you're in pr uh
i think you even promised that all the
pairwise intersections
are are exactly the same okay
okay so oh and also i also say that the
model that's considered here
is um there's public randomness
so there's a public random string in the
sky
every all the players can see this
randomness so when a player decides what
to
send as a message it gets to look at its
input
any message that it got and the public
random string in the sky
in order to decide what to send to the
next player and we're gonna look at
one-way communication here where
player one first sends a message to
player two
who then sends a message to player three
who then sends a message to player four
etc
and eventually this person has to say
one or two they have to decide which
case they're in
so that's the model of computation
that's the model of communication that
we are
studying here right and this public
random stream the sky is basically you
know
you can say a coordination mechanism
right it helps them that they all have
this
common reference string that they can
refer to
and give them some source of entropy and
they only have to succeed with say
constant probability
you know wants to succeed
with probability at least say 90
and the theorem
is that
the total number of bits
communicated
to solve this problem is omega
n over t where t is the number of
players remember
okay and since they're exactly you know
t
minus one messages that are sent right
this implies first of all that um
sum message length
is omega n over t squared
right so that's the that's the
communication
theorem that you know uh mario cephalo
proved in their paper is that
one of the at least one of the players
has to send a message of length at least
n over t squared
bits
yeah oh john you look like you're uh
troubled yeah i'm a bit
this is a bit kind of intuitive to me
why this
complexity actually shrinking t
why the complexity shrinks in t yeah
ah um so actually this is
let me uh
so you think about it this way so first
of all like let's you know
if you think about all these sets having
the same size
okay then um kind of all of them
the hard case the hard case actually is
basically where all the sets have size
roughly n over four t
or you know theta n over t
i mean there are t players the universes
of size n
you know if they have to be disjoint
that means that
you know none of this the average set
size had better be less than n over t
right or at most n over t
so you think all the set sizes are at
most energy so when there are more
players the sets are getting sparser
and then i think there is a protocol
there is a randomized protocol that
basically achieves this so
what does it do um
uh let me just think for a second
so i think it's something like um
each player so let's say each player has
a set of size n over t right
i think what you do is like each player
picks
a one over t fraction of its elements at
random
so that's n over t squared elements and
then
it sends it sends those elements to the
next player
and the next player can detect whether
or not there's there's any kind of
intersection whether any of those
elements are in his set as well
okay now um
if there is an intersection you caught
it with probability if there is
something in the intersection you caught
it with probability one over t
right so and now you have t
you have t chances to run this
experiment because you have t
players right so
the probability that you fail kind of
all t times to catch something in the
intersection
is like one minus one over t to the t
which is a constant
so you have a constant success
probability running this experiment
and each player is sending roughly n
over t squared bits well it's n over t
squared log n
up to a log factor it's achieving it's
achieving this lower bound that i just
said
does that make sense okay
all right good so why does this theorem
imply the lower bound for
for uh lp moment norm estimation
um so
the claim now
is that
estimating
let's say the lp norm up to say 1.1
requires omega n to the 1 minus two over
p
memory
okay and why is that
so case one
is that for all i know equals j okay so
first of all yeah so
what's okay so what is what are the what
are the players going to do before you
get here a little whether please
so
i need to divide i need to use the
existence of a streaming protocol to
devise
a communication protocol or the existing
streaming algorithm to devise a
communication protocol so
these are the players
now there's some streaming algorithm a
so i'll run we'll run a
on the stream
you know containing
all elements of s1
then all elements of s2 etc right
so p1 and it could be a randomized it
could be a randomized
streaming algorithm as well okay so p1
runs a
on on his part of the stream which is s1
then he sends the memory of a
to p2 as a message now p2 can continue
running the streaming algorithm on s2
then send the memory as a message etc
right so if
if pt can then you know
get a good answer based on you know if
p2 can get
you know a good uh answer with good
probability based on the existence of
the streaming algorithm
that implies that will imply that the
memory of the algorithm
has to be omega n over t squared
and then we're going to end up setting
uh
t sorry
we're setting t to be n to the
uh one over p
okay so so what why does this setting of
t where does the setting of t come from
so case one
is that for all um i not equal to j
s i intersect s j is the empty set right
then what do i know i know that the
vector x
is basically you know a zero one vector
right because no item appears twice
so all all frequencies in x all
interesting x are either zero or one
so that implies that the lp number of x
is at most
um let's say the lp to the p
is at most n right
case two
is that let's say there exists some i in
the intersection of all of them
that implies that the lp norm to the p
is at least t to the p
so in fact let me let me make t b 2 n to
the one over p
right so now there's a gap a constant
factor gap between the lp norms and the
two cases so if i can approximate the
lpn optical constant factor i can tell
so that's it so uh i'll set you know and
i'll set t as above
so let's say
this is greater than let's say 2n
if t is as above
okay so that's it
okay so any questions before i move on
okay um so there has there has been work
on you know estimating other norms as
well
um maybe one of the ones i'll
mention is uh
not just alpenarms
uh yeah there was a paper in 2017
this is by joshua washik
uh braverman
chestnut uh kraft gamer and yang
um that you know gives
yeah the exact
complexity space complexity
required you know up to log factors
for any symmetric norm
so what is a symmetric norm it means
that um
you know the norm doesn't change
if you you know if you said if you if
you um
change the sign of any entry
or if you permute the coordinates
okay so any norm that has these two
properties
you know for example lp norms are
symmetric norms right they don't depend
on the
order of the coordinates and they also
don't depend on the signs
um if you have a norm that satisfies
these two conditions
they kind of give one metatheorum that
tells you
that tells you the the ultimate space
complexity of
estimating that norm in the data data
stream
okay um so i think that's all i want to
say about
streaming norms i think in the last 10
minutes i want to talk a little bit
about dimensionality reduction
okay
or actually you know i think what i'll
do is um
rather than do i'll do dimensionality
reduction tomorrow i think because i
have 10 minutes left and what i'll do is
i'll use these last 10 minutes to talk
about
another problem that's solvable with
linear sketching namely the heavy
hitters problem
so let's give myself more pages
okay
okay so
you know we see
items in a stream
you know query words to a search engine
and we want to know
the frequent words
for example the top k tell me what are
the top k
things that you know people are the top
hundred things that people have been
searching for today
okay um
now you can imagine doing this also in
the uh sorry i don't know why it keeps
changing me to erase her but anyway you
can imagine doing this
in the turns you know it doesn't have to
be the turn style model you could
imagine the model where you just see
items and you don't delete items
right i mean that's a very natural model
you can also imagine
wanting to do it in the turnstile model
with deletions if for example
i want to know big differences in
changes in you know in frequency so
you know there's there's the frequency
of words being searched for yesterday
versus today and i want to know what are
the items that had a big change in
frequency
so if i treat all of yesterday as as
plus updates to the x i's
and today as minus updates then x i will
be the difference
in the number of times i searched for
for i between today and yesterday
again imagining again there's this high
dimensional vector x
where x is being indexed by words in the
dictionary right so every time i see
word i
it's like i'm adding 1 to x i i saw you
know x is a histogram of how many times
i saw each word
okay so
it turns out bad news
um kind of exact top k
is impossible
in little of n memory
and you already know the answer to this
why is this the case so i know again
people have to
there's no shared video so um
so i see arnold filter had a question
perhaps so maybe that's from before
but does anyone have a a guess as to
like why
why exact top k is um
why exact top k is impossible in
cellular memory
and ravi i saw your question about yeah
so top one
so top one it's not well okay so
it's related to the infinity norm it's
not it's not the infinity norm
because i'm not outputting a norm right
i'm just telling you i'm just telling
you the identity of the item that
appears most frequently
i'm not telling you how many times he
appeared
um but actually good so actually if i if
i did have to tell you how many times he
appeared yes so let's just let's just
stick with that
then then i am telling you the infinity
norm right
and i know that um estimating the lp
norm
takes memory n to the one minus two over
p so if p is infinity
then estimating the lp norm takes you
know the infinite
estimating the infinity norm takes n
bits of memory right this is exactly the
lower bound that came from
this jointness right if i had
if i had an algorithm that could tell me
the top one where k is one element in
the stream
and it's frequency let's say i could use
that to solve this jointness
so any questions about that
all right so
um i could try to relax this definition
and one way to relax it is
to do the following so
i'll say an item is frequent
or i'll call it um yeah
let me call it kp frequent
k comma p frequent
if
if you look at x i to the p
it's bigger than a one over k fraction
of the sum overall j of x j to the p
and in fact there's something a little
bit
i'm gonna you know there's a another
definition i'm to give instead right now
so this is an okay definition but
there's a there's a stronger definition
and i say stronger for a specific reason
i'll get into but
instead what i'll do is i'll say x i to
the p
is bigger than one over k times the sum
j goes from k plus one to n
of x star j
to the p okay so what does this mean
x star is the vector you obtain
by sorting the entries of x and
decreasing order by magnitude
so x one star you know x one star
is the largest entry magnitude of x x
two star is the second largest entry etc
so you know if x
if x is the vector zero one minus seven
two you know minus four then x star
would be the vector
uh minus seven minus four two one
zero where basically i just sort i just
sort in decreasing order by magnitude
okay so what i'm saying is
x i to the p is bigger than a one over k
fraction
of the of the p at the moment of the
vector restricted to the tail
restricted to everything except for the
top k
okay and can show
kp frequent
basically becomes top k
as p gets large
okay you can show this i'm not gonna
show it
but this is some exercise that this is
some kind of relaxation
there's some kind of relaxation of the
notion of top k
um a smooth relaxation
you know as p gets bigger and bigger
okay so
really you know if i want for what i
actually want to solve is top k
then i you know since i can't solve top
k because unfortunately this jointness
shows me that i can't
there's a there's a lower bound i could
try to solve this you know kp frequent
problem for as large a p as possible
okay and the larger the p i can get kind
of the better
of an approximation it is to the true
top k problem
and then unfortunately it follows
from again the same just jointness
argument
that p greater than two implies you know
kp frequent
requires at least poly and space
so kind of the best relaxation of top k
that i can hope to solve
in low memory is p equals two
and in fact this is achievable
in k log n memory
via the count sketch
right account sketch is that same data
structure i talked about earlier
for l2 estimation and data streams which
gave a faster update time than the ams
sketch because it was very sparse
remember this this matrix that only had
one
one non-zero entry per column
okay so basically what does pi look like
so i'm going to store pi x in memory and
then
there's going to be a query algorithm
that based on pi x lets me recover
the k the frequent items the items that
are k2 frequent
so each entry in pi
i mean so each column of pi has a plus
minus one in a random location and zero
is everywhere else
and the columns are independent of each
other at least pairwise you know
have some amount of independence between
them
so this is the count sketch matrix but
remember
like when with l2 estimation i actually
repeated this
log one you know log whatever delta
times and took a median here i'm also
going to
do something similar i'm going to repeat
this basic data structure
and i can imagine that there are
actually many matrices that i'm stacking
on top of each other
and each one in each column you know i
pick a random location to make it plus
minus one
okay so this is the count sketch matrix
or drawing it a different way
you know here i can imagine let's say
that this is
this has
let's call it b
b entries per per block
and the number of blocks is going to
let's call it r capital r blocks
so the total number of counters or rows
is equal to you know let's say m which
is b
times r right that's kind of the total
memory
i need to maintain b times r counters
so let's draw those counters like this
okay and i'm going to have a hash
function you can imagine i have a hash
function
h1 h2 hr
where each hash function maps me to a
random
entry in that row and then i also have
kind of another hash function that gives
me random signs
and then i also have you know sigma 1
sigma 2 etc
that gives me a random sign
okay and you know
just thinking about what does it mean
that i'm storing pi x in memory
right when someone you know when i see
something in the stream when i see
x i gets to x i plus delta
what do i do now in each
in each one of the rows of this grid of
counters which
a row here correspond corresponds right
a row in that picture
corresponds to a block of counters in
this picture it corresponds to a chunk
of rows here
that's kind of one row of the next slide
right this is row one
this is row two up to like row r
right so going back here right you just
turn that sideways
the top row is the first block the next
row is an x block etc
so in each block in the matrix there's
exactly one non-zero entry
that's that's telling me where i got
hash to
and the random sign there is either plus
or minus one telling me
you know does this delta get
pre-multiplied by plus one or minus one
so when i see an update that looks like
this
that means that for each for each row
here i'm going to add or subtract delta
to one entry at random
right so that's kind of how that's what
it means really to me for me to process
that update in my memory
i'm adding and subtracting delta to
these rows now
suppose i just wanted to know what is x
i i don't want to know the heavy hitters
let's say i don't want to know the
frequent items i just want to know what
is x i
so let's look at this value
or you know that was a plus we could
also look at this value this one was a
minus so
what's in that counter at the end of the
stream
or at query time that counter will have
minus x i
right because it has it has all the
updates
to i but with a minus sign out front
so at query time that value and that
that counter will be minus
x i plus
a sum over all j not equal to i
such that if you apply you know the hash
function let's let's say that this is
row
this is row r or in a row
row t let's say row t if ht
of j is the same as ht of i
times the random sign associated with j
times x j does that make sense
okay that's what's going to be in that
counter
all the mass from i with i's random sign
together with all the weight from all
the other people who collide under the
hash function
with their random signs as well okay
this is the same thing as saying
um right so this is this is basically
just sigma t of i
x i plus the sum j not equal to i
times an indicator of the event that h
t of j equals h t of i
times sigma t of j xj
so a natural thing to a natural way to
estimate x i
we can estimate x i as
you know sigma t i times
that counter
which is equal to x i plus
the sum over j and not equal to i the
indicator of that event
sigma t i sigma tj xj
and this you know is the noise
which has expectation zero because of
the random signs
okay
and
it has expectation zero but what can we
say about like the problem you know
what's the probability that it's large
so remember the noise i said and i'm
almost done i am almost out of time the
noise
is i said the sum of j not equal to i
of the indicator of the event that h t i
equals h t j sigma t i
sigma t j x j right
so what's the probability that the noise
is say
bigger than lambda
by chubby shove this is at most one over
lambda squared
times the expectation of that sum
squared right
and you know first of all
the expectation of this thing is one
over b
right
um so
i'm going to end up setting b to be
something like some large constant times
k if i want to solve approximate top k
and if you do this correctly you can
show that this is at most
1 over lambda squared times 1 over b
times you know big o of
something like x l2 to the fourth or
something like that
you got some bound okay um
so if i set len so if lambda is
something like
uh actually maybe it's one over
kb squared sorry
yeah so
basically if you set lambda to be
something like you know
um
one over root k times the l two number
of x
that is this should be squared yeah
um then this thing here you can
prove will be like kind of at most you
know 1 over 10 or something like that
okay so you can get that basically
the noise is bounded with good
probability where this is the bound
which means that if the item is very
frequent
if the item's frequency is much bigger
than this thing i circled
then you'll get a decent approximation
to the item's frequency
okay and then now how do i how do i turn
that into you know an algorithm to find
the frequent items
well first of all i'm succeeding here
with 90
probability but i don't just have one
counter i have
lots of them i have capital r counters
right capital r is the number of times i
repeated this experiment
so if i take the median of many such
copies
the median of log n copies by a turn off
bound
it'll be a good approximation with
failure probability at most one over
poly m
which means by a union bound i can get a
good approximation to all the indices in
x
so now that i have a good approximation
to all the indices in x i can basically
do a for loop
for i equals 1 to n now get
estimate x i tilde of
x i and then
what i'll do is output the let's say
5k elements that had
the top estimates
okay and i'm not going to go through the
you know justifying why that works but
you can prove that this in fact works
you can prove that if you just do the
estimation procedure i showed you
and then look at that you know over all
n elements what are the elements that
have the top the top estimates
then that will that's guaranteed to
contain anyone who's frequent anyone
who's k
to k comma two frequent according to the
definition of
k comma two frequent that i showed you
earlier okay
so i think i'm over a little bit over
time so um any final questions before we
before we break
so i see ravi has a question about the
l1 l2 norm
that's correct um
you mean like take the l1 of the l2
yeah take yeah you frequently see it
yeah you could start taking
any in general and you know it starts
with a different stuff norms that means
if i take just the plane
yeah go ahead yeah sure whatever i just
want to make sure i understand so you're
saying like you know take the first few
entries take the l1 number of that take
the next view you take the l1 number of
that
and then now take the l2 of all those
numbers is that what you're saying
great yeah so that there has been a work
on that as well
um so if you look there's a paper that
was by jram
and woodruff i wanna say maybe oh
and i don't remember the exact title of
the paper but somewhere in the title it
says cascaded
cascaded norms that's what they call
this right
and they give they do give bounds on
sketching for cascaded norms so that has
that is something that has been studied
oh
thanks thanks for referencing okay no
problem and then i see there's another
question about the lower bound for top k
right so um basically if you do have to
get
the you know an item as well as its
as well as an approximation to its
frequency
then you know that follows from
um the disjointness lower bound so the
point is
right so the point with this jointness
is that
um
you know there's
there's there's one item whose value is
is t his frequency is t so his
contribution to the p if moment is t to
the p
right whereas you know you know that the
entire teeth moment
the entire p moment is at most kind of n
plus t to the p
oh uh john you're muted oh sorry
i thought here you want to estimate
which element is in the top k
not not get the frequency of the top k
yeah but i think you could um so for the
yeah so i mean i think that's also fine
because what you could do is like you
know there are key players in this
jointness problem
right and there's one if it's not
disjoint there's one guy who
every single player has in his set right
so you could do something like you know
use
the first half of the guys will just try
to identify who he is
right does that make sense
you mean which element it is yeah the
first half of the guys will run the
streaming algorithm
and the streaming algorithm will give
the name of that element
if if there is an element that if it's
not the disjoint case
if it's actually something in the
intersection that means that item will
be heavy he will be p
frequent right okay so the streaming
algorithm will tell you his name
and then now they just want to verify
that you know maybe they want to verify
that he actually is
in the intersection so that mid player
that t over two with player
will just say the name to the next
player that's just log n bits
and he'll say hey do you actually have
this in your set
and if he does then you know that you're
not disjoint so you've solved his
jointness
right so yeah so you do get
the lower bound from his jointness does
carry over even if you only need to
identify the name of the item
um samson had a question is there a
sparse version
for faster update time for lp norm
estimation
um there isn't there is there is an
algorithm
that gets faster like instead of
one reps on square time for lp normal
estimation it gets like
it was poly log one over epsilon time um
that's a paper that is by uh
kane nelson me ellie porret
and woodruff in
um 2011.
so that that gives a kind of a fast
optimal space algorithm for lp norm
estimation for p less than two
with faster update time
any other any other questions
have you got additional questions
okay uh don't we thank
you again for stopping and
i'm back tomorrow morning
we're done for the day i'll see you
tomorrow